et si on faisait son épicerie dans le
supermarché des restaurateurs de grands
entrepôts approvisionne les chefs les
commerçants et ces endroits sont peu
connues des consommateurs
on ira touré de cormier délima parce que
ces immenses l'entrepôt ici facilement
plus de 15000 items à bandes ici sous 85
mais picard band
notre créneau premier c'est les
restaurateurs alors l'offre qu'on a
nécessairement s'adresser à eux
c'est peu identifiée au québec ce genre
de marché
[Musique]
je pense qu'on fait face maintenant des
pins si un trésor va bien caché dans le
grand montréal
mir 1
très régional très locale ça existe
depuis 105 ans c'est une entreprise
québécoise qui est présentement en
pleine expansion mayrand club entrepris
au but ce sont des grossistes en
alimentation souvent situés dans des
quartiers industriels sur le bord des
autoroutes et sont ouverts au public
sans frais d'adhésion et ce parfois
depuis plusieurs générations
comme ici chez au but nous rencontrons
julie la propriétaire je pense les gens
ils veulent économiser acheter en gros
qui est beaucoup moins cher que à
l'unité ou un petit format à l'épicerie
est ce qu'on peut me comparer un cosco
absolument pas absolument pas on est
vraiment spécialisés dans la nourriture
qu ce coup
c'est intéressant parce qu'il ya des
télés des ses côtés saisonniers aussi
l'hôte et pas que des temps des livres
des vêtements des ordinateurs nous on
est vraiment ce que vous avez dans votre
cuisine on lit ici dans la plupart de
ses entrepôts on trouve des denrées de
base et plus d'aliments transformés ou
prêtes à manger
il ya des accessoires de cuisine
équipements de restauration mais surtout
des comptoirs d'aliments frais de
poissons de viandes une importante
sélection de fromages et de la démesure
1 2-10 20 kg de farine plus de 20 kg de
pommes de terre 20 litres de mayonnaise
des litres de sauce soya ce que ça peut
paraître un peu gigantesque mais la
laisse à la balle au centre et une
famille peut quand même bénéficier si on
l espace pour pour l'entreposer de
punition est-ce que celui là votre petit
penny qu'est ce qui vous a parlé de
l'espace il y en a chez ce couple de
mont laurier qui plusieurs fois par
année vient faire ses emplettes à laval
qu'est-ce qui vous la peine d'acheter
dans des endroits comme ici le pour
quelqu'un qui connaît pas la lumière des
notes panier
c'est pas mal ce que c'est les pâtes
alimentaires les bases de souple et
comme quand je fais mes sauce à
spaghetti moi ga tout chercher mes
grosses gamme nom va s'affairer bientôt
un enfant parce que ça pas en vite
c'est tout ce qu'ils voulaient à peine
si on calcule acheter toute la petite
canne à 99c poids économique du tout là
de gros format économique oui mais
encore faut-il cuisiner pour ne pas
gaspiller
sinon il est aussi possible d'acheter
certains produits en petites quantités
et est ce que vos prisons ventura ciel
quand on parle de petites quantités ou
pour vraiment sur ces camions c'est
vraiment pas les économies sont faites
pour
en grosse quantité faites-le c'est sûr
je peux pas je peux prendre comme battre
contin mettons un pot de mayonnaise
frites à l'épicerie nous c'est vraiment
gros format pratique quand on est un
groupe qui partage pour des familles
quand on cuisine beaucoup
ou encore quand on cherche un produit de
spécialités acheter des grosses
quantités comme sur fond
je suis né beaucoup là
oui son je vous dirai ma chère madame
entre homos ne purent ces épiceries
entrepôt au modèle d'affaires
particulier comme nous l'expliquent ce
consultant en gestion d'entreprise si on
va retrouver ce genre de produit là de
spécialités qu'un chef aimerait avoir
ces entreprises dont sur véhicule en
état
très préoccupé de la gestion de leurs
coûts et hop missy moins de marketing
moins de personnel
le service est quand même bon mais c'est
sûr qu'on essaie de gérer les coûts de
gérer les frais administratifs pour omer
offrir le meilleur prix au consommateur
on arrive dans bien des cas offrir une
offre aussi intéressante qu'un costco et
walmart dans des créneaux plus limité
mais des fois avec le sommeil 9 plus
spécialisés plus abondants c'est dans
l'entrepôt mayrand que nous rencontrons
nicole roger deux fois par mois elle
vient faire son épicerie ici pour
profiter des aubaines et faire le plein
surtout d'aliments frais fruits et
légumes vous avez acheté quads et des
livres n'est pas j'achète un billet à
prix régulier
c'est seul secret toujours vérifier moi
j'ai l'application rugby a eu sur sa si
j'ai besoin exemple des bananes aussi
banal je vais taper banane qui vont
donner le magasin est ce que c'est le
moins cher
c'est pour ça aujourd'hui je suis ici
aujourd'hui pour nicole le déplacement
est intéressant pour les fraises en
regardant sur son application
elle voit que c'est le meilleur prix
toutes enseignes confondues
c'est la même qu'en feuilles à 405
pourrez donc vous faites 50 sous
d'économies oui par contre oui vu que
c'est un bon prix on voit dans conjugue
gardien banque paul vous allez acheter
lac est complètement sain quand on va
pas faire des confitures
nous avons comparé le prix de quelques
items comme par exemple les oeufs le
beurre et nous avons trouvé des aubaines
semblables ailleurs dans d'autres
épicerie et pour certains produits ce
n'était pas économique du tout comme
pour les céréales acheter une boîte de
céréales de ce poids là est ce prix là
c'est deux fois le prix si c'est sûr que
si on est à titre de consommateurs
intéressés uniquement par les aubaines y
aura toujours moyen d'aller chercher des
aubaines à la si on a le temps de
magasiner
bref il faut magasiner le concept des
coupons c'est encore le meilleur moyen
d'économiser 6 dollars ce paquet oui ce
soit pour cinq kilos c'est sûr quelqu'un
qui vaut comme nous en région les
spéciaux son poteau jour là
donc quand on vient on en achète
beaucoup pour ça
utile pour certains mais il peut être
facile de surconsommer on sent souvent
avec un panier d'épicerie beaucoup plus
garni que au départ ce qu'on aurait
voulu en fonction de nos besoins
or il faut faire attention comme
consommateur il y en a des rabais mais
il faut peut-être se faire une liste de
nos besoins dès le départ avant de
magasiner
c'est vrai que vous achetez trop
s'escrime danger par endroits comme ici
non c'est pas un danger parce que tout
est récupérable tu es maintenant on se
débrouille avec qu'est ce que le tout ce
qui reste
moi je porte sur le tout ce qui reste
pour faire des plats on est à trente
minutes du premier spa marché facture
calculée avec le coût de l'essence qui
est moins d'emballage dans tout son
environnement au dessus ni des avantages
ce serait quoi
le désavantage la proximité ce sont des
entreprises qui ne ne peuvent pas
desservir tous les quartiers à travers
le québec
ça ne peut pas être un seul point
d'achat ici il faudra probablement
complétée en allant dans un autre
supermarché par la suite
il peut donc être intéressant de
découvrir ces lieux d'économies sauf que
l'automobile est un prérequis tout comme
l'espace à la maison et surtout vouloir
tout cuisiné comme le font les chefs